Why does receiving feedback about ourselves sometimes feel like a personal attack even when we know it's meant to help us? In this episode we're unpacking the psychology of feedback, why it stings, why we avoid it and how learning to receive it well can transform our personal and professional growth. I hope you find it super useful. Hi, I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist, and I do love receiving your feedback. You can do that by dropping me a like or a comment, subscribing to the channel, or by getting in contact and letting me know what you think to the content.
为什么收到关于我们自己的反馈时，即使我们知道那是为了帮助我们，有时也会感觉像是一种人身攻击？在这一集中，我们将剖析反馈的心理学，探讨为什么它会让人感到刺痛，为什么我们回避它，以及学会如何正确地接受反馈如何能改变我们的个人和职业成长。希望你觉得这非常有帮助。你好，我是Marianne博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，我非常喜欢收到你们的反馈。你可以通过点赞、评论、订阅频道，或者与我联系并告诉我你对内容的看法来做到这一点。
But I know that especially sometimes if it's unsolicited feedback we're offered, that doesn't always feel quite so nice. And I know when we're in a variety of roles, especially if we're working in mental health, that we need to be kind of aware of our impact on others. We need to be kind of getting regular check-ins from our supervisors, often from our clients and our peers as well, about how we are doing. But that doesn't always feel super comfortable. Sometimes it can feel overwhelming, confusing, sometimes even painful. So today we are exploring why this happens, how it can tie into our deep need for belonging, and offering a few practical ways that can make feedback feel less scary and more empowering.
但我知道，特别是当我们收到未经请求的反馈时，感觉并不总是那么好。我知道当我们担任各种角色时，特别是在心理健康领域工作时，我们需要意识到自己对他人的影响。我们需要定期从主管、客户和同行那里获得反馈，了解我们做得如何。但这并不总是让人感到非常舒服。有时它会让人感到不知所措、困惑，甚至痛苦。所以今天我们要探讨为什么会发生这种情况，它如何与我们对归属感的深层需求联系起来，并提供一些实用的方法，让反馈感觉不那么可怕，而更具赋能作用。
Let's dive in. Number 1. Why feedback can feel like a personal attack. I think it's that it often kind of hits us in our tender spots. It can feel like it's an indication that we are lacking in some way, that we are not enough. That can trigger all sorts of current, past, present imaginings. You know, I'm going to lose my job or they're going to break up with me. I'm not good enough. Others are better. I'm not going to get the pay rise that I need. There can be so many aspects built in. It might also be traumatic things about when people have told you things in not the kindest of ways in the past,
让我们深入探讨。第一点，为什么反馈会感觉像是一种人身攻击。我认为是因为它经常触及我们脆弱的地方。这可能让人觉得是在暗示我们有某种不足，我们不够好。这可能会触发各种过去、现在和未来的想象。你知道，比如“我要丢掉工作了”或者“他们要和我分手了”、“我不够好”、“别人比我强”、“我得不到我需要的加薪”。这其中可能包含很多方面。这也可能与过去人们以不友善的方式对你说话的创伤性经历有关，
that it all comes screaming back to you in the present. It might really tap into your self-worth. It might make you feel that you are not good enough, you are not enough. We've also got to remember that we've got those fantastic, tricky human brains of ours as well, and that being cast out can feel really, really threatening, and that it might well get our fight and flight system into full swing that makes us feel vulnerable and like our position in society
以至于这一切在当下又如潮水般涌回。它可能真的触及了你的自我价值感。它可能让你觉得你不够好，你做得不够。我们还必须记住，我们拥有那些奇妙而又棘手的人类大脑，被排斥的感觉可能真的非常具有威胁性，这很可能会让我们的“战斗或逃跑”系统全面启动，让我们感到脆弱，仿佛我们在社会中的地位
or our pack is at risk. As a result of that, you might notice physical sensations in your body when you're being offered feedback. That might include gurgling stomach, it might include feeling like you need to run to the loo. It really can feel awful. You might find that it makes you feel physically hot, sweaty, flushed. It can be very physically
或者我们的群体处于危险之中。因此，当你收到反馈时，你可能会注意到身体上的感觉。这可能包括胃部翻腾，可能包括感觉需要跑去洗手间。这真的会让人感觉很糟糕。你可能会发现它让你感到身体发热、出汗、脸红。这确实可能在身体上
uncomfortable indeed, not always, but sometimes. And of course that might be for good reason. This might be fear that's being elicited. It might be something that's been so super hard in the past that it gets your pattern matching receptors firing and makes you feel vulnerable and like it's going to happen all over again. Even what they call constructive feedback can trigger this response and make us feel like we are not good enough. And of course, this can be exacerbated,
非常不舒服，虽然不总是这样，但有时确实如此。当然，这可能有充分的理由。这可能是被激发的恐惧。这可能是过去发生过非常艰难的事情，导致你的模式匹配受体被触发，让你感到脆弱，仿佛一切又要重演。即使是所谓的建设性反馈，也可能触发这种反应，让我们觉得不够好。当然，这种情况可能会被加剧，
made even worse with the temperature of our internal self-talk, the way we talk about ourselves. If it feeds into what you already think about yourself, that's when this can feel like a massive sledgehammer blow. So this brings us pretty nicely onto point two, why we would be avoiding of feedback from others. Well, having looked at section one and the responses that we might well be experiencing, it doesn't really feel that wild that we'd want to avoid experiencing all of that and so we might not
甚至因为我们内心自我对话的温度——即我们谈论自己的方式——而变得更糟。如果它迎合了你对自己已有的看法，那就会感觉像是一记沉重的重锤。这很好地引出了第二点，为什么我们会回避他人的反馈。好吧，在看了第一部分以及我们可能经历的反应之后，我们想要避免经历这一切也就不足为奇了，所以我们可能
want to receive feedback from others. But let's take a quick look at some of the reasons why we might feel like we want to avoid that feedback. Well, it might be a fear of shame or humiliation. Perhaps fear of confirming our worst thoughts or doubts about ourselves. Past experiences where feedback was delivered poorly or unkindly.
不想收到他人的反馈。但让我们快速看看我们可能想要回避反馈的一些原因。好吧，这可能是对羞耻或羞辱的恐惧。也许是害怕证实我们对自己最糟糕的想法或怀疑。或者是过去反馈被糟糕或不友善地传达的经历。
There is something called RSD, rejection sensitive dysphoria. That's where it feels even more painful or uncomfortable to receive feedback and where it might always feel like it's critical, like it's kind of stripping you down to the bone, like it's making you want to run away and hide. Those thoughts are spiraling, making you feel like others are better. You should never have done this. Who am I to think I could do this, makes you want to just bury your head in the sand and never come up for air again. And that can be something that is commonly experienced by people with an ADHD diagnosis. If you'd find a standalone episode on RSD
有一种东西叫做RSD，即拒绝敏感性焦虑。在这种情况下，接收反馈会感觉更加痛苦或不舒服，而且它总是让人觉得是在批评，仿佛把你剥得体无完肤，让你想要逃跑和躲藏。那些想法不断盘旋，让你觉得别人更好。你根本不该做这件事。我是谁，竟然认为我能做到这一点？这让你只想把头埋进沙子里，再也不想出来。这在患有ADHD诊断的人群中很常见。如果你觉得关于RSD的独立一集
helpful, please do drop me a comment or connect with me on socials and let me know. OK, number three, how do we begin to be able to receive feedback without falling apart? So my number one tip is to try to stay in the moment. And one of the best ways we can do that is by just taking a moment to pause, make sure you are breathing. Make sure you're not holding your breath because that's when the body might start to go into fight and flight. So we want to try and keep you mindful of being in this moment so that you don't begin
有帮助，请给我留言或在社交媒体上与我联系，让我知道。好的，第三点，我们如何开始在不崩溃的情况下接受反馈？所以我的一号建议是尝试活在当下。最好的方法之一就是花点时间停顿一下，确保你在呼吸。确保你没有屏住呼吸，因为那时身体可能会开始进入“战斗或逃跑”状态。所以我们要尽量让你保持正念，活在当下，这样你就不会开始
to dissociate, you don't begin to start a panic cycle. So once you start to realize that you're receiving feedback, just take a breath. In through your nose. Hold that for a moment. Breathe out through your mouth. to realise that you're receiving feedback just take a breath in through your nose hold that for a moment breathe out through your mouth don't feel that you need to rush in to defend yourself sometimes we just need to be able to listen to hear and that's something that I find really helpful trying to remind myself when I'm parenting as well.
解离，也不会开始恐慌循环。所以一旦你意识到你正在接收反馈，只需深呼吸。通过鼻子吸气。屏住呼吸片刻。通过嘴呼气。不要觉得你需要急于为自己辩护。有时我们只需要能够倾听，去听，这也是我在育儿时发现非常有帮助的一点，我会提醒自己。
Sometimes I just need to listen. I don't need to fix, I just need to hear. Once we begin to be able to pause, to slow things down a bit, that's when we might be able to begin to separate the feedback from our self-worth. To know that one piece of feedback doesn't define you. You know, I guess even with this podcast,
有时我只需要倾听。我不需要去解决问题，我只需要去听。一旦我们开始能够停顿，让事情慢下来一点，我们或许就能开始将反馈与我们的自我价值分离开来。要知道，一条反馈并不能定义你。你知道，我想即使是这个播客，
some people might be like, oh, it's terrible. You're awful. I hate the sound of your voice. You're dreadful. But actually, they might not be the person this podcast is created for. We might be able to think about their opinion or I might be able to think about their opinion as an anomaly. Maybe it doesn't need to be a signal that I'm not cut out for this or that I should jack it all in, quit. Sometimes I can just allow other people to hold opinions that might be different to my own, that might be different to what I wanted or what others, I hope, might think about me. We need to know that that piece of feedback doesn't define us and that it might not also be true.
有些人可能会说，哦，这太糟糕了。你太差劲了。我讨厌你的声音。你太可怕了。但实际上，他们可能不是这个播客的目标受众。我们或许可以把他们的意见看作是一个异常值。也许它不需要成为一个信号，表明我不适合做这个，或者我应该放弃、辞职。有时我可以允许别人持有与我不同的观点，这可能与我想要的或我希望别人对我的看法不同。我们需要知道，那条反馈并不能定义我们，而且它也可能不是事实。
Of course, it might be true, and we might need to be able to consider what changes we can make, how we might reframe what we're doing, do something a little bit differently so that it better meets our needs and the needs of whoever it is we're trying to serve or kind of provide a service for. And another tip can be starting to look for the useful
当然，它可能是真的，我们可能需要考虑我们可以做出什么改变，我们如何重新构建我们正在做的事情，做一些不同的事情，以便它更好地满足我们的需求，以及我们试图服务或提供服务的对象的需要。另一个建议是开始寻找有用的
grain. So even if someone gives you kind of a vitriolic, you know, really not very nice version of their truth, it might be that we can actually kind of dilute it down almost like looking for, if you were doing, I know in Australia once I was looking in opal mines and you were kind of getting like a sand sieve and trying to sieve out all the dirt to look for the tiny opals. And it might be that even within something that feels not very helpful, that there might be a really useful tiny little shiny diamond or opal that maybe is useful for you to take on board. So we can almost discard some of the stuff that feels like actually that's not kind, that's not helpful and just really kind of reduce it down almost to look for anything that might be helpful in going forward
成分。所以即使有人给你一种尖酸刻薄的、真的不太友好的真相版本，我们实际上也可以把它稀释一下，就像寻找——我知道在澳大利亚时，我曾经在蛋白石矿里寻找，你会用一种沙筛，试图筛掉所有的泥土来寻找微小的蛋白石。即使在感觉不太有帮助的事情中，也可能有一个非常有用的、微小的闪亮钻石或蛋白石，也许对你来说是有用的。所以我们可以丢弃一些感觉确实不友善、没帮助的东西，真正地把它精简下来，寻找任何在未来可能有用、
but doesn't feel so personal. I love this next one. It is be curious, not furious. Can you begin to view this as information but not a verdict? We're literally with curiosity just looking at it, just taking a look at what it looks like, what it sounds like, what it feels like and you know just trying to be a bit more zoomed out, a bit more objective. So curious, not furious. We also need to be able to ask clarifying questions. Now this is something that I probably wish I had done at one episode in my life when somebody told me they didn't like my voice and they found it to be the most painful experiences of their lives. I didn't ask for clarification in that moment, but I sure wish I had because
但感觉不那么针对个人的东西。我喜欢接下来这一点。保持好奇，不要愤怒。你能开始把它视为信息而不是判决吗？我们实际上只是带着好奇心看着它，只是看看它看起来是什么样，听起来是什么样，感觉是什么样，你知道，只是尝试稍微退后一步，更客观一点。所以，好奇，不要愤怒。我们还需要能够提出澄清问题。这是我人生中某个阶段可能希望自己做过的事情，当时有人说他们不喜欢我的声音，他们觉得这是他们一生中最痛苦的经历。在那一刻我没有要求澄清，但我真希望我当时做了，因为
that person is no longer with us. So my opportunity to do that has passed. I think nowadays I would be a better self-advocate. I would be better at asking for clarification and also knowing that I don't need to hold on to that. I kind of wish I hadn't because I think it did keep me stuck for quite some years. But an example of a clarifying question might be, can you let me know what you think I could focus on to improve this? So I guess we're looking for things that are tangible, something that helps us to be able to make action steps, you know, something that makes us to be able to make action steps, something that makes it measurable.
那个人已经不在了。所以我这样做的机会已经过去了。我想现在我会更好地为自己辩护。我会更擅长要求澄清，也知道我不需要纠结于此。我有点希望我当时没有纠结，因为我认为它确实让我困住了好几年。但澄清问题的一个例子可能是：你能告诉我你认为我可以在哪些方面改进吗？所以我想我们是在寻找有形的东西，一些能帮助我们采取行动步骤的东西，你知道，一些能让我们采取行动步骤、能被衡量的东西。
When we're looking at goal setting, we're looking at smart goals. So something that's specific, measurable, achievable, realistic, and time-focused. And that might be an approach that would work really well for garnering this feedback as well and putting that into action. We also
当我们设定目标时，我们是在寻找SMART目标。所以要具体、可衡量、可实现、现实且有时限。这可能也是收集反馈并将其付诸行动的一种非常有效的方法。我们还需要
need to begin to notice our triggers. What really gets your goat, so to speak? What are your tender spots? Where are your Achilles heels? If it's always in the same spot, then it might be something that is kind of old stuff that's being brought to the front. It might be that we need to work through that in supervision, in a meeting with someone you care about, with a friend, a family, a loved one, or maybe even therapy too. This can be where reflective journal writing comes in really helpfully as well too.
开始注意我们的触发点。什么真正让你生气，可以这么说？你的脆弱点在哪里？你的阿喀琉斯之踵在哪里？如果它总是在同一个地方，那么这可能是被带到前台的旧东西。我们可能需要在督导中、在与你关心的人、朋友、家人、爱人的会议中，甚至在治疗中解决这个问题。这正是反思性日记写作非常有帮助的地方。
Spend some time with yourself, really invite yourself to look at those tender spots and to think about what might have helped create them to begin with. Number four, let's look at some practical exercises that might be really helpful to help feedback feel less triggering, less awful. We need to reframe our feedback mentally. It might be that we need to notice those thoughts and really name them as thoughts as well. So rather than having the thought that I'm not good enough, you know, we can be like I'm having the thought that I'm not good enough and maybe even shift I'm not good enough to I'm learning. I'm trying to
花点时间与自己相处，真正邀请自己去审视那些脆弱的地方，并思考是什么导致了它们最初的形成。第四点，让我们看看一些可能非常有帮助的实用练习，让反馈感觉不那么具有触发性，不那么糟糕。我们需要在心理上重新构建我们的反馈。我们可能需要注意到那些想法，并真正把它们命名为“想法”。所以，与其有“我不够好”的想法，你知道，我们可以说“我正在产生我不够好的想法”，甚至可以转变为“我正在学习”。我正在尝试
improve my skills which can feel more positive and like you've got more hope and more scope. Keeping a feedback growth journal can be really transformational. Write back any feedback you've received and how you responded in that moment. You might find it helpful to leave some blank spaces underneath so you can revisit so that your future self might have different thoughts, different ways of weighing in
提高我的技能，这会感觉更积极，让你觉得有更多的希望和空间。保持反馈成长日记可以真正带来改变。写下你收到的任何反馈以及你当时是如何回应的。你可能会发现在下面留出一些空白空间很有帮助，这样你以后可以回顾，这样你未来的自己可能会有不同的想法，有不同的方式来权衡
on that same problem. And you might actually one day be able to kind of cross it out and think, actually that's done, I've learned from that. I've incorporated that into my regular day-to-day interactions at work or in a home situation with a friend, with a colleague, with a loved one, a family member. And actually that's not an issue for me anymore. Or you start to get feedback about how well you're doing at that thing and you're like okay job done. This one might feel a little bit more of a struggle and what we're definitely not doing here is we're not
同一个问题。有一天你甚至可能能够把它划掉，心想，其实那已经完成了，我从中吸取了教训。我已经把它融入到我日常的工作互动中，或者在家庭环境中，与朋友、同事、爱人、家庭成员的互动中。其实那对我来说不再是个问题了。或者你开始收到关于你在那件事上做得多好的反馈，你会想，好吧，任务完成。这一条可能感觉更挣扎一点，我们在这里绝对不是在
we're not whitewashing, we're not using positive psychology to make it toxic, we're not gaslighting ourselves but we might be able to be thinking about practising a bit of gratitude. When someone's offering us feedback, hopefully in a constructive way, it's actually that they are invested in our development and they care about us and that they think we can perhaps do better. That is someone who is invested in you, even if it might feel hostile, they want you to thrive, they want you to soar. And being able to hold onto that and like I said, with that sieve, sieving it out to find the useful nuggets, the useful grains of truth that you can hold onto and
粉饰太平，我们不是在利用积极心理学使其变得有毒，我们不是在对自己进行煤气灯操纵，但我们或许可以考虑练习一点感恩。当有人给我们提供反馈时，希望是以建设性的方式，实际上是他们投入了我们的发展，他们关心我们，他们认为我们或许可以做得更好。那是一个为你投入的人，即使它可能感觉带有敌意，他们也希望你茁壮成长，希望你飞翔。能够坚持这一点，就像我说的，用那个筛子，筛出有用的金块，那些你可以坚持下去的、有用的真理颗粒，并且
that do feel comfortable enough to hold onto and to transform and act upon is really key. So have you found this helpful? What's been your take home point? Please do let me know in the comments. And if you've got any other advice, please do drop that in the comments. And if that resonates with you as a watcher or a viewer or a listener,
感觉足够舒服去坚持并转化和行动，这才是关键。那么你觉得这有帮助吗？你的收获是什么？请在评论中告诉我。如果你有任何其他建议，也请在评论中写出来。如果这作为观看者、观众或听众引起了你的共鸣，
please do support other people in the comments as well. If you find this content helpful the kindest thing you can do is to follow the show on whatever platform you are watching or listening to or subscribe if you're on YouTube. Every like on YouTube helps YouTube to know this content is helpful and helps it to be discovered by a wider audience. So please, if you're watching, especially at this point when we're on the finishing lap, please do drop me a like, please do drop me a comment. And if you're not already subscribed, please do me that kindness. It really is the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster or content creator that you rate.
请在评论中支持其他人。如果你觉得这些内容有帮助，你能做的最友善的事情就是在你观看或收听的任何平台上关注这个节目，或者如果你在YouTube上，请订阅。YouTube上的每一个点赞都能帮助YouTube知道这些内容是有帮助的，并帮助它被更广泛的受众发现。所以，请，如果你正在观看，特别是在我们进入最后冲刺阶段的时候，请给我点个赞，请给我留个言。如果你还没有订阅，请对我做那件善事。对于任何你评价的播客或内容创作者来说，这确实是你所能做的最友善的事情。
I would love to know what other content you would find helpful. Please do let me know. Come and connect with me on socials where I'm Dr Maryanne Trent absolutely everywhere. And please do, if you're an aspiring psychologist, come and join my free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr Maryanne Trent, which is the exclusive home of Maryanne's Motivation and Mindset S mindset sessions which happen on Friday mornings. With the aspiring psychologist in the pocket With Dr. Mary Endrit There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我很想知道你还会觉得哪些内容有帮助。请告诉我。来在社交媒体上与我联系，我在所有地方都是Dr Maryanne Trent。如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，请加入我的免费Facebook群组：The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr Maryanne Trent，这是Maryanne的动力与思维模式课程的独家主页，课程在周五早上进行。With the aspiring psychologist in the pocket With Dr. Mary Endrit 本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。